[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian sieers guten
Abend und willkommen im neuen Jahr das
mit Bildern aus Japan beginnt die eine
Katastrophe zeigen und gleichzeitig ein
Wunder ein Flammeninferno heute auf dem
tokota Flughafen Haneda eine landende
Maschine ein Airbus 350 der Japan
Airlines brennt
lichterl und wer das
muss Schlimmstes befürchten aber die
Evakuierung gelingt alle
379 Menschen an Bord kommen raus für
fünf Mitglieder der Besatzung einer
kleinen Maschine der japanischen
Küstenwache die mit dem Airbus
zusammengestoßen war kommt dagegen jede
Hilfe zu spät sie waren eigentlich
unterwegs um selbst zu helfen denn Japan
muss klarkommen mit den Folgen einer
Serie von heftigen Erdbeben gestern an
der Westküste gibt es große Zerstörung
und für die Menschen dort beginnt ein
Kampf gegen die Zeit Elisabeth Schmidt
berichtet hier haben Naturgewalten
gewütet Schiffe die das aufgepeitschte
Meer mühelos auf den Landungssteg
gehoben hat ein sechs Stockwerke hohes
Haus das heftige Erdbeben hatte es so
stark ins Wanken gebracht dass es
komplett zur Seite kippte Stromleitungen
bersten immer wieder brechen Feuer aus
mehrere tausend Häuser melden die
Behörden sein komplett zerstört
Straßen mit tiefen Kratern ein Hindernis
für alle die mit ihrem Auto fliehen
wollen die Straße hier ist unpassierbar
die Risse sind so tief wir mussten
wieder umdrehen es bricht mir das Herz
diese ganze Zerstörung zu sehen ich habe
noch nie so ein heftiges Erdbeben erlebt
und war komplett geschockt ich weiß gar
nicht was ich machen soll alles was
Micki Kobayashi der Verwüstung im Moment
entgegenzusetzen hat sind Schaufel und
und Besen ohnmächtig fühlt sie sich sagt
sie alles ist heruntergefallen die Wand
ist eingestürzt und man kann bis zum
nächsten Zimmer durchsehen ich glaube
nicht dass wir hier noch leben können
noch immer sind Menschen unter Gebäuden
begraben die japanischen Streitkräfte
treffen erst am Vormittag im
Erdbebengebiet ein die Betroffenen
Präfekturen mussten diese Hilfe erst
offiziell in tok beantragen Bürokratie
as usual in einer Ausnahmesituation
einige Gemeinden melden dass Hilfsgüter
knapp werden Schlange stehen für Essen
und Trinkwasser Japans Regierungschef
versucht zu
beschwichtigen seit gestern Abend
bemühen wir uns nach Kräften
Informationen zu sammeln aber viele
Straßen sind blockiert es ist äußerst
schwierig den nördlichen Teil der
Betroffenen Halbinsel zu
erreichen noch immer gibt es Nachbeben
und während den Menschen an Japans
Westküste eine weitere bange Nacht
bevorsteht erschüttert am frühen Abend
die nächste Katastrophe das Land wie ein
Feuerball schießt kurz vor 18 Uhr
Ortszeit die Passagiermaschine der Japan
Airlines in Tokyo hanida über die
Landebahn mit den 379 Menschen an Bord
dem geschulten Flugpersonal ist es wohl
zu verdanken dass alle über Notrutschen
rechtzeitig ins Freie fliehen
[Musik]
können ich habe eine Explosion gehört
etwa 10 Minuten nachdem wir das Flugzeug
verlassen haben ichn sagen das war wie
ein Wunder ein paar Minuten später und
wir wären wohl alle tot
gewesen nach der Landung war der Airbus
aus noch ungeklärten Gründen mit einem
Flugzeug der Küstenwache
zusammengestoßen der Pilot überlebte
schwer verlzt fünf Besatzungsmitglieder
starben die Küstenwache sollte
Hilfsgüter ins Erdbebengebiet bringen
erst Erdbeben dann Inferno Japan mit
einem Jahresbeginn voller
Schrecken unser nächstes Thema heute
Abend eine Kindermannschaft im Fußball
kennt sich ja im allgemeinen schon ganz
gut aus mit Angriff und Deckung aber das
eben rein sportlich gemeint so sieht ein
fußballtrainingslager für die Kleinsten
gerade in der Ukraine aus irgendwie
Deckung suchen vor einem Gegner der den
Tod bringen will vor der nächtelangen
Serie von schweren Luftangriffen mit
denen Russland das Land überzieht
ein Alarm nach dem anderen vor allem in
der Hauptstadt Kiev die Menschen dort
müssen auf ihre Luftabwehr hoffen die
Schwerstarbeit leistet manche sprechen
von den massivsten Luftangriffen seit
Beginn des Krieges meine Kollegin Alisa
jung ist
dort in dieser Nacht schläft niemand
stundenlang heult der Alarm
über Kiev brennt der
Himmel Russland feuert mehr als 100
Raketen auf die Ukraine und schickt
Drohnen in Richtung Hauptstadt mitten in
einem Wohngebiet ein riesiger Krater man
will sich nicht vorstellen wie die Stadt
ohne ihre Luftabwehr
aussä der Welt sage ich danke an jeden
der uns militärisch geholfen hat jedes
einzelne Abwehrsystem hat mindestens
hunderte Leben
gerettet doch es reicht nicht um sie
alle zu schützen in diesem Haus sterben
mindestens zwei Menschen viele weitere
werden verletzt das Gebäude begann zu
wackeln ich dachte es würde ürzen dass
wir eingequetscht würden dass die Wand
runterkommt und das war's aber es
wackelte nur für mehrere Sekunden alles
war mit Staub bedeckt im Nebel ich
konnte nicht sehen es fühlte sich an wie
20 Minuten jetzt weiß ich es waren nur
Sekunden so fordert Außenminister Kleber
von den Unterstützern im Westen neue
Flugabwehrsysteme Drohnen und Raketen
denn Russland greift seit Tagen das
ganze Land an auch die Zivilisten in im
Osten werden wieder zum
Ziel es gibt sehr viele
Verletzte die Zahlen sind bislang nur
vorläufig die meisten sind von
Glassplittern verletzt worden aber wir
erwarten noch mehr
Notfälle Scheiben zerstörte Existenzen
russland will auch die Infrastruktur und
Wirtschaft der Ukraine zerstören
auchinaenos Geschäft in Kiev hat es
getroffen sie fl aus den besetzten
Gebieten hierher hat dieses
tattooostudio vor zwei Wochen erst
eröffnet ich habe diese Erfahrung schon
einmal gemacht dass ich alles verloren
habe und mein Zuhause verlassen musste
und nun habe ich von Null neu
angefangen die Angst vor weiteren
Angriffen ist
groß wo soll ich hin um sicher zu sein
hier in meinem Geschäft im Bunker im CFF
ich weiß es nicht auf der Straße draußen
nirg ist
sicher wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen im
dauerhaften Stress zu
leben Fragen auf die es keine Antwort
gibt schon kommende Nacht kann es wieder
losgehen ja wo stehen wir angesichts
dieser Bilder am Anfang dieses Jahres
das ja das dritte Kriegsjahr werden
dürfte bzw wo steht die Ukraine Fragen
jetzt an den Militärexperten
Gustel rel Herr gressel guten Abend und
willkommen zurück im heutejournal Guten
Abend das ist eine ganze Angriffswelle
die da aktuell läuft aus Russland wie
lange kann die Ukraine sich dagegen noch
einigermaßen wehren das ist ja nicht
auszudenken was noch alles hätte
passieren können wenn ein Großteil der
Angriffe nicht abgewehrt worden
wäre ja aus russischer Sicht gab es hier
eine Umstellung der Taktik anstatt wie
letztes Jahr jede Woche einen Angriff zu
fliegen mit wenigen Flugkörpern hat man
nun im Ganzen Oktober und
November wenige bis gar keine Angriffe
mit teuren Fernwaffen geführt man hat
billige iranische Drohnen verwendet um
die ukrainische luftabweh auszutesten
und dann eben massiv in diesen
Angriffswellen über die Feiertage
zuzuschlagen die ukrainische
Fliegerabwehr kann etwa 70% der
Flugkörper in solchen massiven Wellen
ausschalten bei kleineren Wellen sind es
über 90% und hier hat in Moskau
natürlich irgendjemand sich die St auch
genauer angeschaut und gesehen dass man
mit solchen massiven Angriffen einfach
besser durchkommt und was ist die was
könnte die weitergehende Strategie
hinter all dem sein oder gibt's die gar
nicht über einfach Angst und Schrecken
in der Bevölkerung sehen Russland
produziert etwa 100 dieser dieser Waffen
pro Monat und
[Musik]
man hat jetzt quasi den die Produktion
des Herbstes verschossen ähm das heißt
es wird wahrscheinlich wieder eine Zeit
brauchen bis man aufmunitioniert hat
die Frage die größere Frage ist hier die
Auswah der Ziele es standen eigentlich
jetzt nur zivile Ziele im Vordergrund
Wohnblöcke Hotels Dinge die für die z.B
für die ukrainische Rüstungswirtschaft
eigentlich nicht entscheidend sind die
Ukraine produziert immer mehr gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge sie produziert im
vierstelligen Bereich drohen wenn man
sich die Lage in aufdfk anschaut bringt
das die bringt das erhebliche Erfolge
aber das scheint den Kremmel auch nicht
zu kümmern also hier muss man wirklich
ein Fragezeichen Stellen zu was dient
das solche Luftangriffe die
Zivilbevölkerung wird durch solche
Luftangriffe normalerweise in ihrem
abwehrwillen bestärkt das zeigen ja auch
vergangene Kriege trotzdem hat man den
Eindruck dass Russland so ein bisschen
die Oberhand gewinnt wenn das jetzt so
weitergeht Herr Kessel würden Sie sagen
und das ist ja die ganz große Frage am
Ende gewinnt dann Russland diesen
Krieg Russland ist ist zurzeit in
Initiative und hat in der Tat die
Oberhand auch weil der Westen nicht mit
einem langen Krieg gerechnet hat und
sehr lange gezögert hat entsprechende
industriepolitische Maßnahmen
einzuleiten munitionsproduktion erhöhte
Produktion von
Abwehrraketen wenn der Trend zu
weitergeht dann kann Russland gewinnen
nur der Trend geht in der Regel nicht zu
weiter wenn wir uns an den letzten
Herbst erinnern da stand Russland ganz
schlecht da und wenn der Trend damals
linear so weiter gelaufen wäre hätte die
Ukraine heute schon gewonnen dann hat
natürlich Russland durch
Rüstungsproduktion durch die
Mobilmachung die im Herbst angeordnet
wurde diesen Trend noch einmal umgekehrt
das kann der Westen natürlich auch er
muss nur was dafür machen was muss der
Westen dafür tun um den Trend umzukehren
in erster Linie die Produktion bekannter
Rüstungsgüter ankurbeln wir haben einen
Fehlstand von
Artilleriemunition wir liegen was die
Produktion von fliegerabwehrraketen
angeht weit hinter dem zurück wo wir
eigentlich stehen sollten und dann gibt
es natürlich noch Munition die für die
Front gebraucht wird Waffensysteme die
für die Front gebraucht werden überall
da schauen die Produktionszahlen jetzt
wo die russische Industrie auf
Kriegswirtschaft umgestellt ist
natürlich die Zahlen für Russland gut
aus und für die Ukraine weniger gut die
Produktionskapazitäten im Westen wenn
man sie denn ausschäpfen würde würden
aber eine Trendwende durchaus zulassen
das ist die Analyse am Anfang dieses
Jahres Gustav gressel Militärexperte
herzlichen Dank für ihre Expertise heute
abend vielen herzlichen Dank
und wir bleiben noch ein Moment beim
Thema und zwar mit dir Hanna 18 moderne
Leopard 2 Kampfpanzer hatte Deutschland
der Ukraine geliefert doch nur eine
geringe Zahl ist noch im Einsatz das
geht aus einem Schreiben des grünen
Haushaltspolitiker Sebastian Schäfer an
die Beteiligten Rüstungsunternehmen
hervor zum einen fehle es an
Ersatzteilen zum anderen hätten
Reparaturversuche der Ukrainer zu
weiteren Schäden geführt Schäfer fordert
deshalb eine schnellere bereit Stellung
von Ersatzteilen und bessere
Schulungen in der Türkei wurden 33
Personen festgenommen die nach Angaben
des türkischen Innenministers für den
israelischen Geheimdienst spioniert
haben sollen unter anderem seinen
Entführungen ausländischer Staatsbürger
geplant worden schrieb der Minister auf
X ehemals Twitter gestern hatten in
Istanbul 100000 Menschen gegen das
Vorgehen Israels im Gazastreifen
demonstriert und unter anderem Flaggen
der m geschwenkt das Verhältnis zwischen
der Türkei und Israel hat sich seit
Beginn des gazakriegs deutlich
abgekühlt die AFD konnte 2023 nach
eigenen Angaben einen deutlichen Anstieg
der Mitgliedszahlen verzeichnen und zwar
um
37%. demnach liegt die Zahl aktuell bei
mehr als
40100 zum Vergleich SPD und CDU hatten
Anfang 2023 jeweils mehr als 370 000
Mitglieder die AFD wird mittlerweile in
drei Bundesländern als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch
eingestuft eine der wichtigsten
Bahnstrecken Deutschlands ist für die
kommenden drei Wochen vollständig
gesperrt worden die sogenannte Riedbahn
zwischen Frankfurt am Main und Mannheim
soll auf der gesamten Länge general
saniert werden in den kommenden Wochen
ersetzen rund 1000 Busfahrten pro Tag
den Schienenverkehr etwa 15 000 Reisende
sind betroffen die Strecke für den fern
regional und Güterverkehr verläuft durch
drei Bundesländer ab Juli wird sie für
die Sanierung noch einmal gesperrt dann
für mehrere
Monate es regnet in Deutschland und zwar
ziemlich viel und das ist das
allerletzte was die Menschen in den
Hochwassergebieten jetzt brauchen können
zumal es erstmal auch so weitergehen
soll Dauerregen bis in die Nacht zum
Donnerstag hinein wir haben ja bereits
furchtbare Erfahrungen gemacht in diesem
Land mit
überschwemmungskatastrophen umso mehr
reibt man sich die Augen dass rotes
Kreuz und Feuerwehrverband tatsächlich
immer noch warnen müssen vor massiven
Schwächen bei der
Katastrophenvorsorge sie prangern heute
eklatante Defizite an besonders bei der
materiellen Ausstattung die aktuelle
Lage im Überblick sieht so aus die
rotchraffierten Flächen hier sind
besonders vom Hochwasser betroffen
einzelheiten dazu jetzt von Oliver
deuker über die Ufer getreten Wasser wo
eigentlich Felder Wiesen und Straßen
sind Teile Niedersachsens gleich in
einer
Seenlandschaft die Hunde in Oldenburg
eigentlich ein kleines Flüsschen jetzt
bedroht sie die Menschen im Stadtteil
bümmerstedt halten die Deiche hier ist
die Frage aller Fragen wir sind am
neunten Tag dieses außergewöhnlichen
Ereignisses und die Lage ist nach wie
vor angespannt wir hatten natürlich
jetzt gehofft dass die Pegelstände
sinken aber durch die Regenfälle die
jetzt über Nacht gekommen sind und jetzt
auch bis morgen noch zu erwarten sind
müssen wir noch ein bisschen länger
zittern und arbeiten aber im Großen und
Ganzen haben wir glaube ich die Lage
unter Kontrolle dafür sorgen Sie hier im
Lagezentrum in Oldenburg wo alle
Beteiligten von Bundeswehr bis TAW
zusammensitzen 150 km südöstlich die
aller bei Winsen auch so ein
problemfluss derzeit aufgeweicht die
Deiche bei so manchem hat das Wasser
nicht im Vorgarten Halt gemacht bariane
von holdol wohnt hier seit 40 Jahren ihr
Friseursalon wurde geflutet was immer
ging wurde hochgestellt eigentlich
wollte sie heute nach den Feiertagen
wieder
öffnen ja man ist schon ein bisschen
fertig irgendwo nur auch wenn alles weg
ist was passiert hinterher ne
aber
ja Harz Dauerregen wieder immer noch
satt gefüllt sind die Talsperren aber
nach dem drastischen Wasserablassen über
die Feiertage ist die Situation
beherrschbar zumindest von hier derzeit
Entwarnung
die Situation an talsbern hat sich in
letzten Tagen entspannt wir haben jetzt
nur noch 90% fühgrad das ist immer noch
viel aber ausreichend Platz für neue
hofasereignisse zurück nach Oldenburg
gut die Laune an der sandsackfront die
Zusammenarbeit der Hilfsorganisation
läuft reibungslos aber es gibt auch
Kritik wir brauchen mehr finanzielles
Engagement des Bundes im Bereich des
bundesweiten Bevölkerungsschutzes und
das hat gerade diese Katastrophe jetzt
im
hochwasserbereich im Norden unseres
Landes deutlich gezeigt rund um die Uhr
wird der hundedeich derzeit begangen und
beeugt ob er hält auch eine
Zeitfrage der 8 bis 12 Tag das ist so
die gefährlichste Zeit für den Deich man
geht allerdings davon aus dass in dieser
Zeit eigentlich auch die Wasserstände
sinken wir haben dieses sinkenden
Wasserstände haben wir momentan noch
nicht sodass auch der 13 14 und 15 Tag
auch noch sehr kritisch werden es ist
ein gewaltiges Hochwasser für die Region
für das Land Niedersachsen doch trotz
des Ausmaßes ist es bisher einigermaßen
unter Kontrolle aber es wird dauern bis
das Wasser versiert ist die Flüsse
wieder in ihrem Bett
fließen Fragen an die Präsidentin des
Technischen Hilfswerks nachher hier bei
uns im heute journal
Update der Arm von Israels Militär und
Geheimdiensten reicht weit das ist
allgemein bekannt und es soll allgemein
bekannt sein auch wenn zu den Aktionen
des mossat etwa offiziell nie ein Wort
gesagt wird keine Bestätigung kein
Dementi aber dann doch häufig so ein
wissendes Lächeln heute hat es die
Nummer 2 der Terrororganisation Hamas
getroffen eine Explosion in Beirut
Libanon insgesamt sechs Tote aus Israel
offiziell kein Kommentar inoffiziell
sendet ein Mitglied der Regierungspartei
von Benjamin yaho Glückwünsche an die
Sicherheitskräfte die Aktion kann
erhebliche Folgen haben gleichzeitig tut
sich mitten im Krieg in Israels
Gesellschaft ein alter Graben neu auf
Regierung gegen Justiz ein wegweisendes
Urteil des Obersten Gerichts dass dem
Premierminister alles andere als gefällt
Susanna
Santina knapper hätte die Entscheidung
des Obersten Gerichts nicht ausfallen
können nun ist klar ein Kernelement der
Justizreform der Regierung steht vor dem
Aus zetausende Menschen hatten letztes
Jahr immer wieder dagegen protestiert
dass das Gericht nicht mehr gegen
Entscheidungen der Regierung vorgehen
könnte aus der Wut damals ist heute vor
allem Zufriedenheit
geworden eine kluge Entscheidung ich
hoffe dass die Befürworter der Reform
sie nicht torpedieren sie ist sehr
wichtig für unsere
Demokratie es bestätigt die
Gewaltenteilung es gibt eben eine
Judikative und Exekutive
es wäre besser gewesen wenn das Gericht
gewartet hätte bis diese schwierige Zeit
vorbei ist jetzt brauchen wir vor allem
Einheit für premier netano ist die
Entscheidung ein herber Rückschlag für
Israel eine Bestätigung der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit sagt
Politikwissenschaftler UDI
Sommer es war ein enormer Showdown
zwischen Exekutive und
Judikative die Machtdemonstration des
Obersten Gerichts hat die Koalition
Schranken gewiesen sie wird ihre Ziele
nicht mehr so leicht durchsetzen ich
weiß nicht ob das ihr Ende sein könnte
aber in Israels Geschichte ist das ein
Wendepunkt eine für die israelische
Regierung gute Nachricht kommt am Abend
aus dem Libanon bei einem mutmaßlich
israelischen drohenangriff in Beirut
soll unter den mindestens sieben
getöteten auch der gesuchte Terrorist
sale alaruri sein der als Nummer zwe der
Hamas nach Ismael Hania gilt die Terror
Organisation hat seinen Tod
bestätigt auf der Suche nach weiteren
hamasterroristen gab es auch heute
wieder in Gaza schwere Luftangriffe und
Bodenkämpfe aktuelle Aufnahmen aus Gaza
Stadt zeigen die enorme Zerstörung
85% der 2,3 Millionen Palästinenser
sollen innerhalb Gazas auf der Flucht
sein sie sind meistens in Zelten
untergebracht wie diese Familien
Raffa
es gibt aber auch hier keine Sicherheit
vor allem meine Kinder leben in
ständiger Angst möge Gott uns
beschützen und für Israel hat sich im
Norden nach den fortlaufenden
raketenbeschüssen durch die hisbolla
längst eine neue Front eröffnet der
Führer der Terrororganisation nasralla
hatte gewarnt auf jeden Versuch einer
gezielten Tötung auf dem Boden Libanons
wird es eine harte Antwort von uns
geben nun der hamasf in Beirut getötet
wurde kte age noch mal deutlich
verschärfen so zurück zu uns nach
Deutschland und noch mal du Hanna mit
einer interessanten Statistik ja und
einer Rekordmeldung die Zahl der
Erwerbstätigen in Deutschland war im
vergangenen Jahr so hoch wie noch nie
seit der Wiedervereinigung und das trotz
schwächelnder Wirtschaft Valerie Haller
wie passt das zusammen ja entscheidend
für die Entwicklung war dass der
Wirtschaft wieder mehr Arbeitskräfte zur
Verfügung standen zum einen durch
Wanderung zum anderen waren auch bei der
innländischen Bevölkerung wieder mehr
menschenerwerbstätig damit steigt die
Zahl der Menschen in Lohn und Brot das
dritte Jahr infolge den mit Abstand
größten Zuwachs gab es bei den
Dienstleistungsberufen mit einem Plus
von
295 000 abwärts hingegen geht es bei den
Selbstständigen -3 000 vor allem in
klassischen Branchen wie Handel und
Gastgewerbe hakt es bei der
Unternehmensnachfolge das geht schon so
seit über 10 Jahren für die Industrie
und Handelskammer ist das
besorgniserregend weil ihrzufolge
dadurch viel unternehmerisch
unternehmerisches Potenzial verloren
geht wie sieht denn die Prognose für die
kommenden Jahre aus nicht ganz so gut
Wirtschaftsinstitute gehen davon aus
dass die Erwerbstätigkeit bald ihren
Höhepunkt erreicht hat viele Stellen
sind unbesetzt 1,7 Millionen waren es im
dritten Quartal vergangenes Jahr sie
werden künftig schwerer zu besetzen sein
weil alterungsbedingt wenige
Arbeitskräfte zur Verfügung stehen
babybomer gehen sukzessive in den
Ruhestand selbst überdurchschnittliche
Zuwanderung wird das Expertenmeinung
nach kaum abfedern können vielen Dank
Valerie für deine
Einschätzungen ja und einen weiteren
Rekord gab es im vergangenen Jahr in der
Solarbranche 2023 wurden mehr als eine
Million neue Solaranlagen zur Strom und
Wärmeerzeugung installiert so viele wie
nie zuvor berichtet der Bundes Verband
Solarwirtschaft einen besonders großen
Zuwachs gab es bei den sogenannten
balkonkraftwerken davon sein 270 000 in
Betrieb genommen worden und damit mehr
als viermal so viele wie im
Vorjahr und es gibt eine Unwetterwarnung
des Deutschen Wetterdienstes und zwar
vor ergiebigem Dauerregen in vielen
Teilen
Deutschlands bei der dritten Station der
vierchanzenournee in Innsbruck ist der
derzeit Gesamtführende an Andreas
Wellinger in der Qualifikation nur auf
Platz 15 gesprungen mit einer Weite von
rund 119 m sein Rivale Kobayashi aus
Japan wurde mit
129 m Dritter erster in der
Qualifikation am Berg Isel wurde mit 134
m der Slowene lanisek der bereits
gestern das Neujahrsspringen in
gamischparten Kirchen gewonnen
hatte Hoffnung die bleibt immer zuletzt
hoffentlich gerade jetzt zum
Jahreswechsel haben sich wieder viele
Hoffnung gewünscht Hoffnung kann man
immer brauchen auch im Sport wo die
deutsche
Fußballnationalmannschaft hoffen muss
dass sie die EM im eigenen Land zu ihrer
em machen wird gerade im Sport wo es
hoffnungslose Fälle gibt die dennoch so
viel Hoffnung machen
Tollpatschigkeit und Teamgeist ab
Donnerstag im Kino
es war die peinlichste Niederlage der
Fußballgeschichte mit 31
Gegentoren für eine wir haben nicht ein
einziges Tor in der Geschichte unseres
Landes geschossen seit wir eine
Fußballmannschaft haben ab jetzt wird
sich das ändern ich besor uns ein neu
Trainer und er soll es richten der in
den USA in Ungnade gefallene
Fußballtrainer Thomas R tut miridom das
niemand
gesagt du bist
gefeuert ein das ist deine aktuelle
Situation oder amerikanisch Samoa ist
das euer Ernst rongen soll aus der
damals schlechtesten Nationalmannschaft
der Welt auf Amerikanisch Samoa ein
Gewinnerteam machen die Ankunft in der
neuen Heimat für den gebürtigen
Holländer ein Kulturschock das
resid ihr Schloss erwartet
Sie Ihr Vermieter istion und steht ihnen
724 zur Verfügung
724 von 24 Tagen wir wollen versuchen
dass der Ball im Netz landet und auch
mit dem Training klappt es nur so
bedingt rongen stößt mit seiner
verbissenen Art auf
Unverständnis komm schon Leute dafür
haben wir zu lange und hart gearbeitet
sie sind erst ein paar Tage hier oft
haben wir im Westen so eine feste
Vorstellung von Erfolg und Versagen und
diese Idee Erfolg zu haben wird das
Wichtigste in unserem Leben dort auf der
Insel ist anders wichtig sind da eher
Teamgeist eine positive Einstellung dass
alle gemeinsam etwas durchleben und dass
sie zusammen wieder aufstehen es noch
mal versuchen diese beharlichkeit und
Ausdauer waren wirklich
ansteckend diese Mannschaft hat es
tatsächlich so gegeben amerikanisch
Samoa trat 2011 mit Trainer Thomas
rongen an wenigstens einmal ein Tor in
einem Turnier zu schießen darüber gab es
2014 den Dokument
wins das Spiel ihres Lebens der zur
Inspiration für den Kinofilm
wurde der ist eine sehr leichtfüßige
Komödie geworden gedreht von einem
Regisseur der für seinen skurilen Humor
in Hollywood bekannt ist
Oscarpreisträger
Tati ich bin Polynesier das ist für uns
wichtig uns nie zu ernst zu nehmen und
immer im Hier und Jetzt zu
leben goal wins ein unterhaltsamer Start
ins Kino und Fußballjahr
[Applaus]
2024 können wir gut gebrauchen nehmen
wir gleich einfach so mit ganz großes
Kino jetzt auch im Fernsehen wir nehmen
sie mit in die mega cities dieser Welt
wo irre Abenteuer warten Glitzer und
Dreck wogegen Berlin oder Paris oder Rom
plötzlich wie Siedlungen der
Vergangenheit wirken wo alles größer ist
die Verheißung und die Probleme heute
geht es nach Chong King es ist die
größte Stadt der Welt die niemand kennt
wird Zeit dass ich das ändert jetzt und
zwar hier im ZDF ja und die nächsten
Nachrichten gibt's hier gegen 0:25 Uhr
dann meldet sich Gundula Gause mit
unserem heute journal Update von uns
allen gutes Neues und ein angenehmen
Abend
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend hier sehen Sie die
eindrucksvolle regenspirale von tief
Anneli tief Anneli wird heute Nacht und
morgen über Tag weiter nach Nordosten
ziehen dann gibt es noch kräftige
Regenschauer zum Teil auch Gewitter und
zu den bereits gefallenen 20 bis 40
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter werden bis
Donnerstag vor allen Dingen in den West
und Südwest Staulagen der Mittelgebirge
noch mal bis zu 60 l Regen pro
quadratmer dazu kommen die Wasserstände
von Weser aller Leine Hase und Hunde
werden also wieder ansteigen und es wird
nicht nur sehr nass sondern auch sehr
windig heute Nacht erwarten wir an der
Küste schwere sturmböhnen und den
nordrinwestfalen selbst im Flachland
vielleicht sogar sturmböhnen bis 80 km
pro Stunde das wird also eine sehr
regnerische Nacht und sie bleibt auch
recht mild die tiefstemperaturen liegen
zwischen 10° am niederrein und 4° im
östlichen Bayern oder auch an der Ostsee
und morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
bei 7° im Vogtland oder auch an der
Ostsee und 12° am oberrehein oder auch
in Niederbayern morgen Vormittag regnet
es hier nordöstlich der Elbe noch
kräftig weiter sonst ist es meist stark
bewirkend es gibt kräftige Schauer vor
allen Dingen in den Mittelgebirgen
westlich des Rheins ist auch mal ein
Gewitter dabei und am freundlichsten
wird's wohl noch im Alpenvorland am
Donnerstag ändert sich an diesem Wetter
noch wenig dann dreht der Wind im Norden
erst auf Ost und dann auf nördliche
Richtung und es wird immer kälter guten
Abend